hamilton the musical has finally arrived
on disney plus
bringing the much-loved cultural
phenomenon right into our homes in
glorious hd
and packed into the revolutionary stage
production are tons of incredible
details that even some ardent hamill
fans may have missed yupikai movie
lovers i'm
jan and in this video i'm revealing 22
crucial things that will make you love
the hamilton movie even more
jonathan groff's deliciously fun
performance of king george's breakup
song you'll be back it's a great comic
moment
[Music]
and the british monarch's very
particular walk when he first arrives on
stage has a curious origin which graff
attributes to the incredibly heavy crown
he initially had to wear in the role
adding to the difficulty of his stage
entrance was that groth had to balance
the weighty headpiece while advancing
forward in heels one foot in front of
the other as if walking on a tightrope
or while wearing an incredibly thick and
heavy royal gown
the song's cheery sensibility and
musical style which is a clever hat tip
to the beatles and the 60s british
invasion deliberately contrasts with the
rest of the musical to show how king
george is intruding on events
the song also squeezes in some neat
references to both the boston tea party
and the king's future mental illness and
funnily enough the track's inspiration
came from british actor hugh laurie who
lim manuel miranda worked with
previously
when miranda explained he was writing a
breakup letter from king george to the
colonies laurie wagged his finger and
said ah you'll be back
a detail that many fans didn't miss in
the hammer film
is the profuse amount of spit that
emerges from king george as he threatens
his ex-colonial subjects
and now don't change the subject
now some might have thought it was a nod
to the king's insanity later in life
but it's actually because jonathan groff
is a spitter whenever he performs on
broadway
in an interview with variety groff
explained i've always been a spitter
i start sweating i just get wet when i
perform on stage
it's just what happens interestingly
when this production of hamilton was
filmed back in june 2016
groth was no longer playing king george
so rory o'malley the actor who'd taken
over the role very nobly stood down
so groff could temporarily reign once
more and the film crew could capture the
magic of the original broadway cast
together again
and that's why you'll see o'malley's
name pop-up and the special thanks
during the movie's credits
satisfied is one of the musical's most
popular numbers
in particular thanks to renee elise
goldsberry's breathtaking delivery of
some incredibly fast lines so this is
what it feels like to match
with someone at your level what the hell
is the catching and the innovative way
the song pauses time
then rewinds is also perfect setup for
time stopping later in the show when
aaron burr fires his gun in his jewel
with hamilton
but one of the most intriguing things
about watching the hammer film
versus seeing the show live in the
theatre is that the way the movie is
shot and edited creates a different
experience
when editing satisfied for the movie
director thomas kale revealed they could
be more subjective with the camera so it
feels like we're going inside angelica's
brain
the cut pattern is quite accelerated and
the camera angles are quite varied
so for me watching at home what this
does is that it creates a real sense of
the confusion angelica
feels as she deals with her conflicting
emotions kale
also added that this cinematic technique
of rapidly cutting between different
perspectives is similar to how the song
breaks the form of the theatrical
language and the theater
by the way the movies edited with
footage from recordings of two live
performances together with the third day
when the cast was filmed in an empty
theater to get
all those great close-up shots oh and if
you watch
very closely you may spot the odd tiny
continuity error
for example in satisfied the flowers on
angelica's dress are sometimes present
while other times they just disappear as
the film switches between footage from
different days
a sweet reminder that hamilton was made
by human geniuses and not robots
hamilton isn't just a musical about a
revolution its musical style is also
revolutionary in terms of musical
theatre because it packs such an
incredible number of words into its two
and a half hour story
writer leia labresco calculated the
speed of the show's songs and discovered
the fastest ones clocked in at an
amazing
200 words per minute with an overall
average of 144 words per minute
goldsberry expertly delivers 121 words
in just 24 seconds for angelic
angelica's fastest first and satisfied
the conversation two minutes maybe three
minutes
while in guns and ships david diggs
squeezes 19 words into just
three seconds
in fact labresco found that if hamilton
was sung at the pace of other comparable
broadway shows
it would run for somewhere between four
and six hours
another example of miranda playing with
tempo is the opening number which
recounts the first two decades of
alexander hamilton's life
the song runs at a steady pace as the
protagonist is introduced but when
hamilton discovers the way out of his
predicament is to double down on his
education
the tempo of the rap picks up doubling
in speed
it's not just the speed of the songs in
hamilton that's fascinating though but
also as david diggs pointed out
miranda has each character perform in a
different style
for example george washington raps in a
very metronomic way which is similar to
how he thinks
all right on beat no i'm the model of
the modern major general the venerated
virginian veteran and diggs's character
lafayette progresses from a simple 80s
rap cadence at first
i dream of life without a monarchy the
unrest in france will lead to america
and by the end he's rapping in double
and triple time
actors try to put themselves in the
shoes of their characters so chris
jackson who plays george washington
wrestle with the fact that washington
was a slave owner and that the country's
first president along with the other
founding fathers failed to abolish
slavery when they created the union
in the book hamilton the revolution
jackson says that it didn't keep him
from getting to the heart of who
washington was and trying to betray the
truth in that
and he even found a way to address this
conflict in the musical
at the very end when eliza sings that
hamilton would have done more to end
slavery if he'd lived longer
watch jackson just behind her carefully
and notice how he bows his head in shame
which was his way for washington to
accept responsibility for what he did
and didn't do by the way alexander
hamilton's anti-slavery credentials have
been
questioned by some historians who say
the musical paints him in an overly
positive light something i go into in
detail in my hamilton fact or fiction
video
links will be here and in the video
description as soon as it's ready
the musical set design is also packed
with lots of details that reflect both
the pre
and post-revolutionary era of the united
states as hamilton's creative director
and designer david corins has explained
this is the story of the people who
built the scaffolding upon which the
country was built so
you see wooden period scaffolding up
around a half-made wall to show a kind
of aspirational space
giving it the feel of a colonial era
building under construction
and during the musical's intermission
the brick walls get bigger growing eight
feet taller to represent the continuous
work being done on the country
and how the foundation is growing by the
way fun fact those brick walls aren't
brick at
all but a pressed pattern board that's
then cut off and treated with goop and
texture paint and layers of distressing
on top
corins has also said that the use of
turntables on the stage is inspired by
the whirlwind of history that sweeps up
hamilton
as well as the literal hurricane that
hits the caribbean island where he was
born
and it also matches the cyclical
relationship between aaron burr and
hamilton where they were basically
spiraling around each other their entire
careers and lives
like the line immigrants we get the job
done which always gets huge applause in
the theater
the show's set design also has its own
way of honoring the immigrants that
helped build america
corons has said that since many
immigrants arrived via boat they wanted
to feature nautical elements in their
set designs which is why there's lots of
ropes and pulleys and the wooden
structures are built using the same
elements used in ship building of the
era
the show's choreography also plays a
crucial part in creating
subtle effects to complement the story
at any particular time
for example when hamilton arrives in
helpless both angelica and eliza are
positioned along his line of sight
and in this moment he locks eyes with
eliza when the moment is rewound and
satisfied hamilton's position switches
over
and this time he's looking at angelica
the direction in which the turntable
moves also communicates a subtle meaning
but choreographer andy blankenbueller
counterclockwise motion like that in
helpless suggests time passing
the opposite direction however implies
there is resistance to the inevitable
going on which is why the turntable
reverses its motion during satisfied
lankan bueller explains that many in the
audience won't consciously register his
choices like the fact that burr moves in
straight lines because he sees no
options and hamilton moves and arcs
because he sees all possibilities
but viewers still feel it intuitively
again this small detail
helps to communicate the difference in
world view of two of the most important
characters in the show
now hamilton the movie doesn't exactly
have a post-credits scene but there
is a little bonus for anyone who sticks
around to the very end of the 10 minute
long credits
in the film's final two minutes you get
to hear the exit music which is a medley
of hamilton songs that isn't on the
official soundtrack
this musical piece is a jam session
recorded live with most of the original
band members which plays for the
audience as they leave the theater and
is a delight for any hammer fans who
haven't had the pleasure of hearing this
until the movie came out
and check out the special thanks part of
the credits and you'll see lin manuel
mirandas included all the curious places
he wrote hamilton over the years
including the a train where he wrote
wait for it hamilton's birthplace nevis
where he can pose non-stop
and on his honeymoon where he wrote
you'll be back
of course one of the joys of hamilton
arriving on disney plus is that not only
can howell fans watch it on repeat but
those of us who couldn't experience it
live can finally see the much talked
about musical
but even now disney plus or other
streaming services like netflix or
youtube are sometimes blocked in the
country where you live which is why i
want to thank the sponsor of this video
nordvpn a vpn or virtual private network
helps you bypass
geo restrictions or censorship on
content not available to view in your
country
with a vpn you can just pick a server in
another location and browse the internet
as if you were there
here at flicks in the city we've tested
several vpns and nord is one of the best
and
fastest it has over 5 000 servers to
choose from in over 60 countries
and when connected to nord we were still
able to get blisteringly fast download
speeds
a vpn also helps protect your privacy by
encrypting your internet connection and
preventing your isp
government agencies or malicious hackers
from reading your emails private
messages or knowing which websites
you're visiting
unlike many free vpns nord has a no log
policy
meaning it doesn't record or retain
details of your online activity when
you're connected to its service
nordvpn also works with netflix disney
plus and other tv streaming services
like amazon prime to help you connect to
those
and work around geo restrictions for a
limited time nordvpn are offering all
our viewers
up to 70 off new subscriptions just
visit nordvpn.com
flicks or tap the link in the video
description to access the offer
so what are your favorite moments and
songs in hamilton and did you notice any
other interesting details
leave your thoughts in the comments
below tap left to learn about everything
the musical changed about the real
history of alexander hamilton
or tap right for something else you're
sure to like and thanks so much to all
of you for helping me reach a million
subscribers since i last
uploaded i really hope you're all
keeping safe during these tough times
thanks again for watching and see you
next time yupikai movie lovers